.
THERE IS NO GENERAL GEORGE
WASHINGTON COMING TO SAVE US.
JOINING US IS INDEPENDENT
JOURNALIST GLENN GREENWALD.
YOU HAVE BEEN EXPOSING SOME OF
THE NONSENSE COMING FROM DEEP
STATE OPERATORS AND INTELLIGENCE
OPERATORS FOR A LONG TIME.
WHEN WE ARE ON THE CUSP OF A
WORLD WAR-TYPE SCENARIO, THAT
NOBODY CAN TRUST ANYTHING THAT
COMES FROM THE GOVERNMENT?
>> YOU GO BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
SIN IN 2002 AND 2003, THAT A
TODAY HUSSEIN HAD A NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
AND THAT TURNED OUT TO BE
UNTRUE.
AND I THINK WHAT REALLY
UNDERMINED IT MORE THAN ANYTHING
WAS THE MANUFACTURING OF RUSSIA
GAIT IN THE 2016 ELECTION FOR
PURELY POLITICAL REASONS.
TO INTERFERE IN THE ELECTIONS.
REMEMBER THE PEOPLE WHO SAID
TRUMP HAD COMMUNICATIONS WITH
ALPHA BANK IN RUSSIA.
THE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP WAS
RUSSIAN MISINFORMATION.
AND THE HAVANA BRAIN DAMAGE THAT
WAS CAUSED BY HAVANA IN U.S.
DIPLOMATS.
OBVIOUSLY WE ARE REASONABLY
SCEPTICAL BECAUSE WE KNOW THEY
LIE ALL THE TIME.
IT'S DANGEROUS THAT WE HAVE NO
PART OF OUR GOVERNMENT SO WE CAN
UNDERSTAND WHO REALLY DID BLOW
UP THIS PIPELINE AND WHY.
DAN: YOU ARE A JOURNALIST, AN
ACTUAL JOURNALIST.
WE WERE UNDER THE IMPRESSION,
WHISTLEBLOWERS BLOWING THE
WHISTLE.
VINDMAN WAS LIONIZED.
HE WAS LIKE A HERO.
NOW WE HAVE FBI WHISTLEBLOWERS
TALK ABOUT ABUSING S.W.A.T.
TEAMS.
INTELLIGENCE CASE FILES ON
AMERICANS.
BUT ALMOST NO MAINSTREAM COMING
AT ALL.
>> YOU KNOW, IF YOU QUESTION
BACK TO THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, I THINK ONE OF
THE MOST OVERLOOKED PART OF WHAT
THEY DID IS THEY WAGED AN ACTUAL
WAR ON PRESS FREEDOM.
BY BRINGING OUT THIS HUNDRED
YEAR OLD LAW, THE ESPIONAGE ACT
AND USING IT TO PROSECUTE ALL
WHISTLEBLOWERS.
A HUNDRED-YEAR-OLD LAW DESIGNED.
AND THIS WAR ON WHISTLEBLOWERS
CONTINUED.
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO GET THE
WHISTLEBLOWER TITLE ARE THOSE
WHO ADVANCE THE LEFT'S AGENDA.
AND PENAL WARNING THERE IS
POLITICIZED CORRUPTION IN THE
FBI ARE PROSECUTED OR IGNORES
BECAUSE THE MEDIA IT SELL IS AN
ARM OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I NEVER USED TO BELIEVE THAT.
BUT IN 2015 IT'S IMPOSSIBLE